[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you I'm so glad you're happy I
don't know why things are going Czech
Republic country did you see this week
Muller finally came down from his cloud
focus you know everybody's been waiting
for him to speaker to testify and he
finally spoke and what he said was
word-for-word the report is my testimony
I shall not want
that was so get off my lawn and stop
asking me to testify and do anything
make do with my cryptic pronouncements
this is what he said he said I love this
if we had confidence that the president
clearly did not commit a crime we would
have said that okay so is he a criminal
what he why say it that way what was his
wedding like do you Robert take this
woman I don't not take her
Trump speaks in playground
What did he say no do-overs
I get that you know it's a little
trickier to say I didn't not find
evidence so you do don't have to leave
it to Congress and when I say do don't
what I really mean is don't do and we
just want to know did Trump work with
the Russians and mothers like you know
it's a little like sex with your
ex-girlfriend who hates you but you're
both horny you wouldn't call it planning
but you both want the same thing
thank you for applauding my breakdown
now you know Trump's tweet about this
yesterday was priceless have started
with Russia Russia Russia President Jan
Brady ladies and gentlemen is Russia
Russia Russia and then this guy he'll
deny everything all day and then
completely admit it on Twitter he said I
had nothing to do with Russia helping me
to get elected
and then of course an hour later he has
to walk it back no no the election
wasn't stolen it fell off a truck what
did I say but liberals have a new hero
congressman Republican congressman
Justin Amash liberals love any
Republican and comes out against Trump
or like a a gay guy on Grindr who only
gets excited by straight guy I'm telling
you something between this Justin Amash
and robert muller for what it was the
pro-impeachment now has mojo you can
tell it dies because Trump is scared
Trump said the other day impeach was a
dirty disgusting filthy word and don't
even get me started on ethics
but yeah 55 Democrats now or for
impeachment but of course most of the
Democrats are still saying hey yeah
impeachment but what most people care
about are the issues can't you do both
you know Missouri now has one abortion
clinic Missouri Republicans are gonna
have to send their mistresses to
Illinois I mean you can't run on that
Louisiana now got on the abortion
bandwagon that's sweeping the nation
this last month they voted in the
legislature to ban all abortions even in
case of rape or incest and there was one
redneck in the back of the room who
stuck up his hand and said does that
include second cousins
yeah come on least me but they're
sanctimonious about abortion but they're
they're running Roy Moore again it looks
like an Alabama rut run Roy Moore wants
to run again for the Senate in Alabama
he's got a great slogan
oh yeah it's a when I'm in DC I can't
[ __ ] your kids don't get all excited it
looks like looks like even if every
Moore won he would not be able to serve
his term because the Senate is within
one mile of a school the big policy news
that broke today is that Trump has come
up with yet another ingenious plan to
stop immigration tariffs tariffs solve
everything okay
he says if Mexico doesn't stop the
immigration coming through the border
also from Central America through Mexico
he's gonna start putting tariffs on
everything Mexican starting at 5% on and
going up to 25% in October this is on
Mexican companies and everything Mexico
sends here ok so now we're going to
build a wall and Taco Bell is gonna pay
for that is that that's where we are now
of course you know he never seems to
understand Mexico or any country doesn't
pay for tariffs we pay for tariffs and
these tariffs from Mexico our biggest
partner fruits vegetable not just that
but cars this they say will increase the
price of a new car $1,300
Mexico isn't gonna pay for the wall
you're gonna pay a lot more for that
muffler and of course liberals are
incensed about this not about the cars
but do not [ __ ] with the price of
avocado toast
you